Speaker 1: So a radical Republican, Trump
is Congressman Madison Cawthorn, who knows
nothing about history, nothing about foreign
policy, nothing about geopolitics, nothing
about economics.
Nothing about mathematics.
Nothing.
OK, you got it.
He has been taking the also very friendly
to Russia approach of just criticizing Ukraine,
but criticizing Ukraine for things which really
Russia can be more heavily criticized for,
including a lack of democracy and so on and
so forth.
And this is just beyond parody.
Madison Cawthorn did some kind of a public
event, and someone in the audience said they
wanted to know more about what's really going
on in Russia and Ukraine.
And hilariously, they want Madison to explain
it to them, which is just so funny.
Like why on earth would you go to him?
But let's take a look at the clip and see
him trot out even more extreme versions of
the same talking points.
Speaker 2: Anybody else?
Yeah.
Can't you, sir?
We got this mess in the Eastern Europe there
with Ukraine and all that.
I know you've made some reference to President
Zelensky being involved or being in the government
being corrupt.
We're all I think we're all trying to figure
this thing out.
I mean, it seems like we're on the precipice
of what could be a possible major disaster.
Can you clarify some of that for us so we
know where we stand
Speaker 1: now before we even hear the answer?
Did this Madison Cawthorn doesn't know anything.
This guy looks like he's, you know, 55, 60,
65, I don't know how ignorant is he that to
find out what's going on with geopolitics.
He goes to an event with a clueless congressman
and asks him, Tell me what's really going
on?
Speaker 2: OK, I will.
So one, as I was saying earlier, there's so
much propaganda coming out on all sides of
this, both from Russia, from Ukraine and a
lot of other countries and more from our own
media that things are becoming so murky and
hard to understand.
Speaker 1: But so that's also a really popular
talking point they use.
It's just so complicated that UFC guy Bryce
Mitchell also did it.
We get it.
We don't know what's going on.
It's crazy.
Speaker 2: Before we all jump to conclusions
saying we're going to go defend defending
democracy in Eastern Europe, we have to realize
that there is.
The Ukrainian government is so well known
for corruption.
Speaker 1: Now remember, the Russian government
is more well known for corruption, and Russia
still invaded Ukraine.
Speaker 2: There was only one of the major
sex trafficking hubs of the entire world,
not the.
Speaker 1: Russia is also a major sex trafficking
trafficking hub of the world, and it doesn't
justify the Russian invasion of Ukraine
Speaker 2: in that area.
The Ukrainian people are wonderful people.
There's a lot of really great people on those
who are patriotically fighting for their freedom.
I commend them.
They're doing great.
But this is not a country that you know, I
feel like is the shining beacon of what really,
truly is the standard of a good and clean
and transparent government.
Speaker 1: And Russia is even less a standard
of good in clean and transparent government
on any freedom and democracy index.
Ukraine ranks far higher than Russia.
But either way, Russia invaded Ukraine.
So it's it's not only is he ignoring Russia's
record, he's ignoring that none of it would
justify an invasion anyway.
Speaker 2: And so there was a lot of corruption
has been there.
You know, in 2014, there was basically regime
change that happened.
You know, there's there's just a lot of questions
and questionable issues going on there.
I do plan on releasing in detail in a few
weeks as kind of something with some ideas
and some thoughts.
Speaker 1: And I imagine waiting around for
Madison Cawthorn report with ideas.
OK, so beyond parody, here's a bonus clip.
Madison Cawthorn In the context of all of
this strife, he mentions the Bible, but he
doesn't even know what he's talking about
when he mentions the Bible.
Speaker 2: There would be easy to get disheartened
with the things going on not only in our country,
but in our world today.
Their war is breaking out, you know, in revelation
records of other rewards and leaders of wars.
I think it's exactly what we're seeing.
Speaker 1: So not number one.
I don't know what the hell the Bible has to
do with any of this, but his references are
also incorrect.
Wars and rumors of wars is from Mark and from
Matthew.
I mean, I don't even care about this stuff,
but he just happens to be wrong in Mark 13:05.
Jesus said to them, Watch out that no one
deceives you.
Many will come in my name claiming I am he
and will deceive many.
When you hear of wars and rumors of wars do
not be alarmed.
Matthew, 24 four Jesus answered, Watch out
that no one deceives you.
For many will come in my name claiming I am
the messiah and will deceive many.
You will hear of wars and rumors of wars,
but see to it that you are not alarmed.
Do they even care that the Bible stuff he's
quoting is inaccurate?
Does anything matter at this point when people
are going and asking Madison Cawthorn for
his view on geopolitics?
My instinct is the facts don't matter.
We'll have these clips on our Instagram at
David Pakman show.